we're just a nice normal family you know
like we don't learn we don't have
anything outrageous really happening
things have definitely changed since
then seven months into the college
admissions scandal a source tells ET
it's been the biggest challenge of
Laurie locklins life adding that she
never imagined her public persona would
plummet or that she could face jail time
quote this has affected every aspect of
her life but lucky for Laurie it seems
her kids have rallied around her and our
source says her only saving grace has
been how close her family has become
since the scandal broke I don't really
care about school as you guys Rory's 20
year old daughter Olivia Jade who
attended USC prior to news of the
scandal initially cut herself off from
her mother but according to our source
there's been a complete turnaround and
both of Laurie's daughters have quote
joined together because they both feel
their mother only wanted the best for
them so I want to be supportive of
everything they want to do but I do want
them to have somewhat of a normal you
know finish out high school college
experience meanwhile our source says
that Laurie has been trying to see
positive and maintains that she's a good
person that meant no wrong adding that
she's standing by her decision to share
an attorney with her husband and not
take a plea what's more the source says
that Laurie hopes she'll beat the
charges when the judge hears her story
for he claims that she and her husband
were scammed by Ric singer and that she
always thought the money was going to a
charity through the school according to
our source Laurie doesn't feel for one
minute they were breaking the law you
know we're here once that we know of go
for the go for the gold right you've got
to do it meanwhile our source says the
actresses anxiety is through the roof
adding quote she is terrified and she's
been consumed with trying to put on a
happy face but it's not easy under the
circumstances
you're learning something and or you're
second-guessing your moves as a parent
and you're hoping you haven't done
permanent damage and you know you're
struggling you're trying to do the best
that you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]